good morning Hank it's Tuesday I wake up
every morning after a few hours of sleep
with 500 miles stuck in my head when I
wake up well you know I'm gonna have
this freaking song in my head I pack up
head out to the van that I still cannot
believe exists and then drive 500 miles
or whatever to the next place the van is
very comfortable and we have neck
pillows but it's impossible to sleep in
there because one it's not a bed and two
there is an Xbox and so all we ever do
is beat the holy living crap out of each
other's pixels we arrive early afternoon
and find lots of books needing
signatures and hang corphish's which
takes a couple hours although
fortunately I have a fair bit of
experience in the field of signing my
name and Hank I'd wager that you've
drawn more anglerfishes than anyone
alive on the planet and before you tell
me that the plural of anglerfishes
anglerfish wikipedia it then the people
start to show up and there are a lot of
them they wear my face on their torso or
Doctor Who shirts and they bring book
cakes and they have things I wrote
tattooed on their bodies sometimes in
borderline inappropriate places all of
which is amazing and beautiful and also
of course completely terrifying then we
have a quick meeting with Hank song
this is AG sock mug stage or the show
little Norma's but uh a lot of people
how they are I can see them through the
crack in the cart and it's time to start
the show
Hank writing is something you do alone
it's a profession for introverts who
want to tell you a story but don't want
to make eye contact while telling it and
on some level writing is the exact
opposite of this
then I read and talked about The Fault
in Our Stars and you sing some songs I
answer some questions you wear a tutu we
answer questions together and whoever is
talking when the timer goes off gets
shocked with the charlie is so cool like
patented shocker
then you send some more songs and people
dance and it feels magical and
otherworldly to be in a room full of
people who feel unembarrassed if their
enthusiasm and intellect
and then we sign for five hours which I
won't show you much of because the only
thing more boring than standing in line
is watching other people stand in line
then we get to the hotel around 2:00
a.m. I sleep for a few hours and wake up
with 500 miles in my head grateful and
astonished to have the readers and the
brother I've looked into Hank I'll see
you on Friday